Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute machen wir Spritzgebäck.
Ich habe schon ein Spritzgebäck Rezept auf meinem Kanal online, das ist sehr, sehr alt.
Aber ich wollte es gerne mal wieder in Erinnerung rufen weil ihr braucht für mein Rezept nicht viel Zeit
und keine sonderbaren Gebäckpressen etc. also wirklich super easy!
Entweder nehmt ihr jetzt eure Küchenmaschine oder euer Handrührgerät. Und als allererstes gebe ich da-
(Hamza: Als allererstes: Kiki hast du eine neue Frisur?!)
Ja aber Hamza das ist peinlich, mach das nicht!
So, die zimmerwarme Butter gebe ich jetzt hier -
(Hamza: Ist's reingefallen?)
Aber nur ein Stück!
(Hamza: Ja ist doch gut, mach weiter! *lacht*)
Zum Glück nicht daneben gefallen!
So, die gebe ich jetzt hier rein und dazu kommt auch noch Puderzucker.
Ich nehme bei diesem Rezept gerne Puderzucker und nicht Kristallzucker.
Das verbindet sich dann besser und es soll ja auch ein schnelles Rezept sein ohne viel Tamtam. *Handy-Benachrichtigungston*
So.. und jetzt 2min lang verrühren.
Und Hamza das nächste Mal schaltest du dein Handy bitte aus vor dem Dreh, Danke!
(Hamza: Oh, tut mir leid, Frau Lehrerin!)
So und jetzt dürft ihr euch entscheiden: Macht ihr da geriebene Zitronenschale z.B. rein,
geriebene Orangenschale? Achtet da nur drauf, dass es Bio ist.
Oder z.B. Vanilleextrakt oder das Mark einer Vanilleschote?
Ich hab natürlich immer mein Extrakt da und gebe davon jetzt ein bisschen was rein.
Und als nächstes - ah, eine Prise Salz!
Die hebt nochmal den schönen süßen Geschmack.
(Hamza: Boah, wie oft ich diesen Satz schon gehört habe!)
Muss ich immer dazusagen weil manche wundern sich
warum bei süßen Gerichten eine Prise Salz reinkommt - das hebt einfach den Geschmack!
So und jetzt Mehl und Speisestärke dazugeben.
Ich siebe das, rühre das ganz kurz ein und lasse dann so 2-3 Schlücke Milch dazugeben
damit sich das einfach zu einer richtig schönen Masse verbindet.
So und als nächstes müssen wir die relativ feste Masse in einen Spritzbeutel geben, da habe ich jetzt eine Sterntülle vorne dran.
Und jetzt könnt ihr ganz einfach wie auch bei einer Gebäckpresse
- nur dass ihr jetzt halt anstelle der Gebäckpresse euren Spritzbeutel verwendet -
könnt ihr da Kreise aufspritzen oder einfach nur eine Schlange, also ein "S".
Und die Backzeit ist auch sehr kurz.
Also die Kreise, die sehen mir ein bisschen dicker aus als meine "S"e,
als meine Fragezeichen oder wie auch immer man das nennen soll!
Und daher backe ich die Kreise bei 190° C Ober- und Unterhitze für 10min
Und die anderen werde ich glaube ich nach 9min schon rausholen aber jeder Backofen backt anders
daher schaut gerne nach 8min schon mal rein.
Die dürfen auch nicht zu dunkel werden. Und dann werde ich sie nach dem Backen noch mit Kuvertüre so ein bisschen beschmücken.
Die Vollmilchkuvertüre jetzt ganz grob hacken und 2/3 davon überm Wasserbad schmelzen,
dann herunternehmen und das restliche Drittel hinzufügen.
Und so habt ihr die Kuvertüre ganz einfach temperiert und sie glänzt später schön und hat keinen Grauschleier.
So und mein Spritzgebäck - zumindest die runden - sind jetzt schön abgekühlt.
Also so müssen sie aussehen.
Hier noch relativ hell, vielleicht noch  nur an der Spitze ein bisschen goldbraun
und die Rückseite darf ruhig goldbraun werden.
Aber dunkler als das darf es nicht sein, so sind sie nämlich richtig schön mürbe.
Und die anderen sind im Ofen, der piept auch jede Sekunde.
Dann lasse ich die auch vollständig auskühlen und werd dort die Spitzen mit Kuvertüre überziehen.
Hier mach ich's so: da gebe ich ganz einfach die Hälfte in meine temperierte Kuvertüre.
Und dann hab ich mir noch überlegt - das gibt's nämlich so auch fertig zu kaufen -
dass ich da auch noch Kokosraspeln oben drüber streue.
(Hamza: Oh jaaa!)
Das lieb ich!
Das lieb ich, das mach ich dann gleich noch zum Schluss.
Und das wäre es schon gewesen!
Und jetzt würden die - also "würden" sage ich extra weil sie glaube ich nicht so lange halten
aber sie würden prinzipiell jetzt mindestens 3 Wochen luftdicht verpackt halten.
Und ich mag's am liebsten zum Kaffee oder zum Tee und ihr könnt sie jetzt ganz einfach nachmachen
indem ihr hier unten unter dem Titel die Videobeschreibung aufklappt,
euch die Zutaten anschaut. Macht 'nen Screenshot, geht zu Kaufland einkaufen.
Und dann freue ich mich über eure Fotos mit #kikiskitchen auf Instagram!
Und ich würde mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf meinem Kanal, Tschüss!
Okay!
(Kiki: Action!)
Action!
Also Leute! Wir haben uns gedacht: "Okay, das Video ist vorbei."
Und wir haben uns gedacht: "Komm, wir probieren einfach!" Also ich probier einfach.
(Kiki: Guck mal Hamza, du probierst, ja? Und dann lässt du deinen Gefühlen so richtig freien Lauf!)
(Hamza: ..freien Lauf!)
Wir haben's gleichzeitig gesagt, eigentlich musst du mir ne Cola ausgeben!
Wie? Also ich - ich..
Also ich mag das gerne, jetzt hier anzufassen, ne?
(Kiki: Ja, genau!)
Damit man nicht die Schokolade anfasst und die schmilzt, sondern so..
(Kiki: Ja!)
Mmh, mürbe! Boah!
Boah!
(Kiki: Voll zart, ne?)
Boah, das schmeckt hammer lecker! Das schmeckt auch so frisch.
Wenn man sowas fertig kauft, dann ist es meistens etwas härter und man merkt einfach, dass es irgendwie industriell hergestellt wurde.
Aber das: das schmeckt richtig frisch, aber extremst frisch!
Eigentlich brauch ich das mit Kokos gar nicht probieren weil es eigentlich das gleiche ist, nur mit Kokos.
Aber ich mag Kokos, also die Kokosraspeln. Deswegen probier ich jetzt einfach mal mit Kokos.
Mh! Mmmmh!
(Kiki: Was gefällt dir besser?)
Also ich muss sagen: Die Kokosraspeln dominieren doch mehr als man denkt.
Schmeckt schon nen Ticken geiler. Ja, das schmeckt echt ein bisschen besser finde ich.
Ja mit den Kokosraspeln finde ich schmeckt das - also das harmoniert hammer gut zusammen!
Also ich find auch ehrlich gesagt: Ich hab noch nie so gute Kekse gegessen, also so frische Kekse gegessen!
(Kiki: Also, was lernen wir daraus? Es sind manchmal die einfachen Dinge im Leben, oder?)
M-hm!
Frisch schmeckt das echt einen Ticken geiler. Ist einfach so, selbstgemacht.
Gerade glaub ich zu Kaffee schmeckt das hammer lecker!
(Kiki: Ja!)
Und, was heißt das für dich?
(Kiki: Öfter backen!)
Kaffee machen!
(Kiki: Achso! *lacht*)
Also Leute: Ciao!
(Kiki: Ich hab nicht Play gedrückt!)
What now? Mm-hm!
(Kiki: Wirklich nicht!)
Mm-hm!
Ehrlich jetzt?!
(Kiki: Jaa, wir müssen nochmal!)